Ah, the Game of Life.
It’s about as offensive as a bowl of Jello.
But the original one from a hundred years
earlier?
It had squares like...this.
The first Game of Life wasn’t just a game.
It was a form of moral instruction.
And it says something about how society thinks
life should be lived then and now.
In a way, the Game of Life started when this
chin disappeared.
Milton Bradley was a young lithographer — basically
a printer — in Massachusetts when he made
a thousand prints of this man running
for president in 1860.
When Abraham Lincoln grew a beard, those prints
were worthless.
So Bradley had to pivot.
He took his printing skills and let them loose
on a young medium: board games.
The Checkered Game of Life was his first game
— and it became a hit.
Players started at infancy.
They spun a teetotum — this thing — to
determine options for their move.
You had control to choose your
move once you spun.
The goal was to hit 100 points, through 5-point milestones like college, and Congress,
or big ones, like 50 points for Old Age.
The game’s patent shows that Milton
Bradley’s Life was more than just a social
game.
It was about great moral principles.
Elizabeth Peabody founded the first English
kindergarten in the United States in 1860.
Milton Bradley published this portrait of
her well after his Lincoln failure.
He also volunteered to teach his own daughter’s
kindergarten class in Springfield, Massachusetts,
after the success of Life.
And he used his business, Milton Bradley and
Company, to publish games and educational
tools, including more than 40 books about
the new Kindergarten curriculum.
They made a wide variety of learning tools,
from educational puzzles to influential color
wheels.
Education became Bradley’s passion, and
the original Game of Life predicted that — it
was a way to teach “the checkered journey
of life” to children — and adults.
That weird spinner, the teetotum?
That was originally to avoid cards and dice,
because they were associated with gambling.
The location of each spot also taught a lesson.
Old age was surrounded by many difficulties.
“Poverty lies near the cradle,” but passing
through it didn’t hurt you in the beginning
of the game.
Setbacks didn't earn you points, but most
didn't kick you out of the game, either.
Honesty led to happiness.
Industry, to wealth.
And perseverance led to success.
“I made 50,000 in the stock market today.”
“That’s Life”
In 1960, long after Milton Bradley died, the
company — which by then was mostly making
games — dug Life from the archives, choosing
it over a long list of other games the company
had once published.
They adapted it to 1960s America with a candy-colored
spinner and stacks of cash and cars that could
load up a full family of baby boomers to places
like Millionaire Acres.
“I went to the Poor Farm.”
“I’m on Millionaire Acres!”
It centered around paydays, where the value
of winning a Nobel was the cash prize that came
with it.
The winner is the person with the most money.
Today’s versions are almost identical, with
tweaks for jobs and hot brand integrations.
“That’s life.”
There was no more disgrace but there also
wasn’t bravery, or honor, or truth.
Both versions are the Game of Life.
Which one should we play?
So when game night is over, you want your
home to be safe - and that’s where Simplisafe
comes in.
They are the sponsor of this video.
Simplisafe’s effective, reliable home security
that’ll make sure your home is safe.
It’s easy to use.
Easier than this thing, for sure.
Do you know how many times I had to spin this
thing for this video?
So what makes Simplisafe protect like a Pro?
They’ve got 24/7 professional monitoring,
and police dispatch that’s 3.5 times faster.
So if there’s a break-in - hopefully there’s
not a break-in, but if there is a break-in, the police
will be called and they’ll get there really
quick.
And they’re modern comprehensive.
That means they’ve got interior
and exterior sensors to help keep track of
things.
Experts like that, 3 million people like that
- a lot of people like that.
This is not part of the ad.
This is for sustenance.
So all of this is about 50 cents a day with
no contracts.
There’s hardware too.
They’ve got the Simplisafe Lock, which always
makes sure that your door’s locked.
Simple as that - a lot of break-ins happen
just because the door is unlocked.
I know I’ve done that — I’ve run ten
minutes back to my house just to lock the
door.
Simplisafe takes care of that.
It also keeps track of people and lets you
grant remote access.
So protect all those beloved peg people in
your life!
Head over to Simplisafe.com/VOX
One more time, that’s Simplisafe.com/VOX
Simplisafe doesn’t directly impact our editorial
but their support makes videos like this possible.